auschwitz war das größte deutsche
konzentrations und vernichtungslager
1940 hatten die nationalsozialisten mit
dem bau in der nähe der heute
südpolnischen stadt oswiecim begonnen
aufgrund der zentralen lage im deutsch
besetzten europa wurden circa 1,3
millionen menschen aus fast allen
regionen nach auschwitz deportiert
über eine million juden aber auch
kriegsgefangene politisch verfolgte roma
sind die zeugen jehovas homosexuelle
auschwitz war das größte konzentrations
und vernichtungslager der nazis aber
längst nicht das einzige
hier ein blick auf die größten in
treblinka zum beispiel wurden
schätzungsweise etwa 900.000 menschen
ermordet auschwitz bestand aus drei
haupt und über 40 nebenlagern das größte
hauptlager entsteht 1941 auschwitz
birkenau
es bestand aus über 300 baracken in
denen zeitweise rund 90.000 menschen
gleichzeitig untergebracht waren die
meisten hierher deportierten aber wurden
nach ihrer ankunft für nicht
arbeitsfähig befunden und direkt in den
gaskammern ermordet und danach verbrannt
die übrigen häftlinge wurden zur arbeit
gezwungen bis zur tödlichen erschöpfung
viele kamen auch durch krankheit
unterernährung und misshandlungen um
insgesamt wurden etwa 1,1 millionen
menschen hier ermordet auschwitz wurde
zum symbol des industriell organisierten
massenmordes am 27 januar 1945 wurde
auschwitz schließlich durch truppen der
roten armee befreit